all right welcome everybody john perry
here i am accompanied by dr. Caitlin
kite welcome hello she she is how did we
meet you we met we met online probably
we had I think we had some mutual
interests and shared contacts and we
were on social media feed together yeah
yeah you'd bought him a t-shirt and you
say that yeah I stated clearly t-shirt
and you sent a photo of you doing it was
the Darwin day hike yep yeah that was in
that was in England somewhere right that
was it yeah yeah there's been a couple
now so I forget which one that one was
but it got I think it was in the New
Forest and that shirt did get quite a
lot of attention during the hike that
day yeah cool and then we met in real
life we met two years ago at tetazoo con
that's right yeah yeah so Tezuka con for
those who don't know is a conference
about tetrapod zoology that's put on by
dr. darren naish and he's he's an
anthropologist yeah zoologist I guess
you describe him he's got a podcast the
tetsu podcast which is absolutely
wonderful and he's got his tetazoo blog
that he's been writing on for like years
and years and years and I went down
there it's a really cool mix of science
art and you know researchers working
together to do you know work on projects
together and just kind of appreciate the
science of zoology so that's where we
that's where dr. Kate and I first met
and his first met in real life but it
was after years of us talking back and
forth so it was it was really cool to
finally finally meet up and now you've
just written a book and I've got you on
my show but I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself because I just want to
do some quick announcements real quick
so obviously I am back to doing Sunday
morning science broadcasts I moved which
is why I had to
Soph but I am now in Canada and I'm in a
different time zone but I'm still gonna
keep doing this at the 10:00 a.m.
Pacific time because you know now that's
that's one in the afternoon from me
which is kind of nice I can sleep in on
Sundays but the no in Montreal the I
have an interview tonight with Shannon Q
she's gonna be talking with me about the
debate that I did a couple weeks ago
about the genetic code is the genetic
code a real code and so we'll kind of go
over how all that went down so watch
that tonight at that 9 p.m. East Coast
time so at midnight Pacific time and
it'll be we're gonna do it live but
it'll also be available to watch
afterwards and then on the 6th I am
doing a debate with Perry Marshall Perry
Marshall is he's been on the show before
he is I don't want to describe him wrong
because he doesn't he doesn't like being
called the creationists but he's he
leans towards creationism and we're
gonna be talking specifically about
teleology and purpose so do organisms as
their purpose and the way that animals
are built that is their teleology in
biology so that that's we're gonna be
talking about he's got kind of a well
yeah a non-standard view on that and I
say debate but basically it Perry
Marshall for those of you who saw the
last time he was on he's really smart
guy he's really fun to hang out with and
chat with about things and he's he
hasn't really interesting insights even
though he disagrees with most biologists
and he disagrees with me on a lot of
things so it would be fun but we're
recording that on the 6th and I'm not
sure if he's gonna want to do that live
or not because we've had a yeah in the
past we've pretty recorded things and
then edited things down which we might
do this time as well it's kind of tricky
to do a debate without a moderator it's
just gonna be him and I without you know
things getting heated or ego offer
weird tangent so we'll edit some stuff
out but anyway so that's my schedule for
this upcoming week next Sunday unless I
get someone to come on and to do a live
show with I will be doing a video about
essentially The Selfish Gene different
papers that look at biology look at
genetics the genome as a collection of
genes that are either cooperating with
each other or competing against each
other even in the same genome there's
some really interesting research that's
been going on with this or you look at
genes as organisms and you look at the
genome as an ecological system it's
really really cool stuff you probably
know that you know this term The Selfish
Gene comes from Richard Dawkins work
that was I think back in the 70s not
really his research but a book that he
wrote summarizing research that other
people had done and a lot has changed
since then some of the things he he he
kind of over exaggerated in his original
book not over exaggerated at the time it
was all accurate but some things have
changed a little bit and we'll kind of
go over where things are today so
that'll be pretty fun but all right so
back to dr. kite here you have written a
book which was very lovely I got to read
it this week I ordered it and the
hardcopy didn't come but you sent me a
PDF because you're so awesome
so that I could get caught up before
don't tell my publishers okay hopefully
they're not watching yeah but anyway
tell us about your book right so my book
is called flamingos and it's a part of
something called the animal series and
I'm allowed to say this without bias
because I reviewed the series before I
contributed to it and they're really
pretty books and they're really
interesting that got amazing images and
lots of really interesting content a
huge breadth of different authors so
people who have some very different
perspectives on the animals that they're
writing about so I had read a bunch of
the bird ones prior to writing mine
and I think if I recall correctly I'm I
was the first person who was actually a
biologist to write about the birds in
the bird part of the series and I think
that's quite interesting they had
anthropologists and other types of
people thinking about birds and everyone
has their own different perspective so I
tried to ground it a bit more in the
science I guess right now so so this
this series had been going on for a
while not not people necessarily with a
scientific background that we're writing
these but your book is very I mean you
it's flamingoes is the book and you go
into basically you summarize our current
knowledge on flamingos I mean yeah you
go in depth and what do we call a book
like this
that's just summarizing the scientific
literature on a specific topic is there
like a specific name where's this is
genre or yeah I have a really hard time
when people ask me to describe it
because in a way it is pop science you
know popular science but about half of
the book is not really science it's
culture so you could call it natural
history or cultural history so I always
do kind of say it's a natural and
cultural history of the Flamingo and so
I can't really think of a more succinct
way really to describe that type of work
yeah it's a review of the literature and
that happens to be in that kind of realm
mm-hmm yeah written a review of the
literature basically for the public now
now within the scientific literature
actually I don't want to get ahead of
myself we'll talk about that in a minute
but the I mean the book is great I just
it's it talks about all the different
species of flamingos it talks about the
history of flamingos in humans like what
people have thought of them
it talks there's there's so many
different things that that it discusses
and there's some really crazy facts in
there and I'm just wondering from you
what what is the craziest fact about
flamingos that everyone should know but
they don't right so there's really only
one answer to this question I think and
it's the answer I always give and it
feels a bit boring
at this point but that is the fact that
filming goes have in their mouths and
and their throats what we would
basically classify as a reptile tissue
so it's exactly the same sort of tissue
that you would find giving erections in
male mammals and this is what flamingos
have in their mouths and throats so that
when they are inverted and feeding with
the tops of their heads facing down and
there it's sucking water back through as
they're trying to filter feed that gives
them the necessary pressure to keep that
process happening so that they can pump
the water through and get the little
animals out of the water and into their
mouths so I think it's fascinating and
you can see some really great images of
the vasculature in their mouths so that
you can see where there are all these
nerves and blood vessels that allow this
to happen yeah that was yeah that would
be the one that stuck out to me the most
as well independently we didn't plan
this in advance yeah flamingos have
erectile tissue in their mouths so I
think something is kind of interesting
that most people don't know is that we
actually have a little bit of a rectal
tissue in our noses mammals do which
helps regulate it'll things it'll
inflame and then go down according to
temperature to help regulate moisture
intake and so on but it's interesting to
see such a developed structure in the
mouth of a bird which does that exist in
other birds not that I'm aware of it it
is really unique to the way that they
feed and they are one of very few
organisms that has this kind of
upside-down pattern of feeding yeah and
if none of you have seen this well first
of all the buyer books you'll see all
kinds of photos of it but if you want to
watch it there's tons of videos if you
just type in flamingo feeding you can
watch flamingos feeding and they just
put their head upside down and they're
just in the water and they're just it
looks like they're kind of like munch
munching on the water and they're just
there their mouth is when they open and
close it just acts like this pump water
just goes through it's kind of squirting
does it squirt out the back
yeah they kind of are like whales in a
sense with the baleen but and flamingos
it's called lamellae so yeah they're
kind of just squishing it through the
lamellae and then back out the size yeah
and yeah they're yeah they're filtering
the water like like you said just like a
whale super fascinating creatures really
weird animals there and and aside from
all that the things we talked about
flamingos maybe we do another day where
we just talked about flamingos the whole
time but the thing that's been most on
my mind lately is how do we process the
scientific literature how do we
understand the scientific like how do we
navigate it because you know I most
people in my audience are outside of the
scientific field but even people in the
scientific field like the work that you
did on this book required you to become
an expert on flamingo literature and
I've talked about this before in my
channel but in science an expert is
someone that knows what's what has been
studied what has not been studied what
the debates are in a particular field
they understand that field the research
that's been done and the research that's
being done and you are I mean I would
say after writing a book like this you
you must be like the you know the top 10
people on flamingo expertise you know
yeah you know this literature in it so
many of us get in in marketing now so
right now I'm like you know I'm I'm I'm
in my 30s and starting to gain the belly
weight that's kind of typical of a man
in his 30s and I don't want to because I
know that it's bad for me to let that go
so I've been trying to learn a little
bit about weight loss like healthy
weight loss or just a better way to live
my life more healthy as far as diet goes
and exercise and trying to navigate the
literature on this is absolutely insane
people are marketing all kinds of stuff
to me for weight loss and that there
seems to be contradictions in the
literature when you're going to a new
field may be something you're not super
familiar with and I know you're you're
primary research when you're getting
your PhD was not on flamingo
specifically it was on you did a lot of
work with birds but so I would imagine
that this was kind of a new field for
you right just flamingos in general yeah
very much how do you just start into the
literature from cold basically yeah it
makes sense of what's going on it's
actually something I'm doing again right
now because I am an academic developer
so I hate people and you have to know
the education pedagogy and that's not my
background and so anytime you approach a
new topic
I always feel quite nervous because
you're so aware of your own boundaries
and your own limitations and you're
aware that other people know where to
start and that you don't and you don't
know who's considered good and what
research has considered good so for me
one of the best things is being able to
use Google to to see it to do a quick
scan of what people have written about
informally and then to find out who are
the names that keep popping up what are
the certain buzz words or key ideas that
keep coming up because that will then
help you to do a better search when
you're looking for the literature and it
will help you kind of hone who is most
respected I guess and when you do that
you can also you can pick a few of those
people's papers or papers on that sort
of topic and see what is cited and who
is cited within those and that will
start opening doors and so you start
having this growing mound of literature
on your desk and I think one of the
really useful things that we talked
about the term earlier review so anytime
you can find a review article where
someone who is an expert in the field is
summarizing all that is known from all
the other experts in the field that's
really helpful and those don't always
exist
you know reviews are written often by
PhD students as a first chapter so they
they might publish those but you don't
always have a review in your particular
field so that's that's always kind of a
nice thing to stumble on when it's
relevant well that brings up a good
point let's talk about that
I guess the different types of papers
that you find I mean there's there's in
biology I guess there's the
like fieldwork papers where people are
just describing what they've seen in the
field you've got in the lab experiments
and then you've got these review papers
if you can kind of explain the
difference between well if anything that
I'm missing as well what types of papers
you'll find so a review paper is
something that's basically saying this
is the state of the field today
so I wrote one of these and that came
out of my first chapter of my
dissertation where all of us have to
review everyone else that's gone before
and you kind of summarize that and a
really good review is not just one where
you're saying here is the sum total of
what we know it's one where you're then
taking that to propose some new ideas so
reviews might just be old stuff but it
might also be some new stuff to push
things forward then you might have
something where it's your what we would
typically call a my field at least your
experimental chapter where you are
talking about you know here is the
question that I had here is what I was
trying to answer here are the things
that I did to get there and then these
were the results and here's what I think
we now know about the field and here are
the new questions that we have to follow
up on mm-hmm and then you will also have
things where someone perhaps is just
saying this is a new technique that we
might want to try and so someone might
just be purely describing a methodology
and I'll saying right now someone go out
and do that and tell me what it's like
or you might have something where
someone is being theoretical in another
fashion where they are for example
running a model or they are drawing up
diagrams and just saying you know
logically this makes sense here's a new
way of thinking what do you guys think
so there are lots of different ways to
just kind of propose new ideas without
doing the experiment or basing off of
someone else and are in a review style
and then as you said there might be
things where people are purely just kind
of describing their own experiences you
know it's we often have these anecdotal
types of papers where you're saying this
is not a full-scale study but this was a
really interesting thing I saw take this
information and make of it what you will
yeah and that so those I think are the
main types in my particular field I'm
sure that other areas of science are
even
search have other types as well yeah
yeah so if you are brand-new to a
subject you recommend heading for these
review articles yeah definitely if those
exist then the whole point of a review
is that someone is pulling together 30
40 50 different papers that have been
written and they're usually the key
paper is with the key arguments and so
if you've got the review then right
there you've got a list of all the main
things that you probably should read and
even if you can't read them all you'll
at least have a good summary of what
they say so you have a really quick way
to wrap your mind around what are the
main questions we still have and how do
we get to where we are today yeah and
these review papers you know they have
width and then they have links to all
the different research articles that
they're basing their review paper on so
you can actually go back and and look at
the the actual experiments as well but
so I guess just to kind of summarize
where we're at right now in this
conversation in the scientific
literature a lot of what you find are
reports on experiments reports on
observations and if you just start
digging into that you can get lost I
mean you've got you've got thousands and
thousands of papers to read just to
learn understand you know what we know
about flamingos for example but if you
go to the reviews people who are experts
in the field are going to have
summarized the bulk of the research so
far now obviously there's going to be
conflicts right and in research so what
are the things that I see all the time
is that people will argue you know for
right now like I said I've been looking
at how to live eat a healthier diet and
I'll find people saying that sugar is
the enemy added sugars the enemies some
people say that fruit even just eating
fruit is bad for obesity and then other
people are saying that fruit is super
healthy but you shouldn't have added
sugar like there there's all these
conflicting research in these
experiments and this is super common by
the way in anything studying human
psychology or human diet and so on
because we can't really do very good
experiments on humans because we're not
allowed to we can't we can't just you
know there's lots of ethical issues
involved with experimenting on humans
and so it's it's very difficult we have
to do these these really broad
statistical analyses of of people's diet
choices and so on to try and figure out
what types of diets are the healthiest
so there's actually a lot of conflict
there's there's very little I guess
resolution to problems that happen that
occur in human nutrition research but I
you know I've just noticed that there
there are some pretty dramatic
contradicting opinions the different
scientists have based on their research
maybe there wasn't that and flamingo's
but how do you deal with especially if
you had to reviewers review papers that
are contradicting each other how do you
deal with that conflict so I did
actually have though there was one
obvious conflict that came up when I was
reviewing flamingo and it wasn't well I
guess it kind of wasn't a bit of a
review paper so they were there have
been a couple of different camps arguing
over flamingo evolution for a couple of
decades now actually and I think we've
gotten to the point where it's pretty
conclusively been decided what Fumiko
evolution looks like but at the time
that these papers would had come out
that I got in my hands on so in the 80s
90s early 2000s these people kept
arguing back and forth saying look we're
looking at these characteristics and it
clearly shows from lingos are most
closely related to these birds and then
there would be another argue argument or
response to that paper saying no it's
definitely these things we're looking at
these and and you know I'm not an expert
enough to actually be able to
distinguish and these people are experts
claiming something very different and so
the best that I could do is read the
things that they're citing readers
around the issues so they were saying
you know we're using genetics we're
using brood parasites or shape of the
egg all sorts of different
characteristics that they're saying that
this is how you can tell so I could read
around those characteristics and get a
sense of what they were using to base
their arguments on and then you just
kind of come up with your own opinion or
you do the unsatisfactory kind of
political journalistic thing of saying
well there is this argument out there
and no one really knows but here is what
they think and I think actually it is a
really good thing where if you aren't
entirely sure then you probably should
admit it even if you are trying to
become the expert and it's your own
paper that you're writing and you're
saying you know actually we don't know
this yet or I haven't proven this yet
but the evidence says this but you can
always do have the option of course of
reaching out to people and asking them
directly so you could just approach if
not the people who were in the argument
then some other third party and say well
what's your impression what do you think
yeah you know I'd like to get to how
accessible scientists are in a second
but this this this question of conflicts
a lot of people think that if there's a
scientific paper about it then it's true
and that is definitely not the case the
scientific scientific literature is
where people report on their experiments
they report on their data and then they
put forth their conclusions they put
forth their their ideas about what's
actually happening here and the
scientific literature is where
scientists go to argue with each other I
mean a paper that's peer reviewed and
published in a journal it's been peer
reviewed so people have have read over
it to make sure that it's not just total
garbage but that doesn't mean that the
conclusions are false it doesn't mean
that the data is good even it means that
it looks like the data is good and it
looks like the conclusions they're
coming to follow the data but that's all
I mean you'll see people arguing back
and forth in the literature all the time
and I see this with people that are
especially they're trying to sell you
diet or products or herbal products they
are
you know vitamins and stuff they are
they'll cite at paper and they'll say oh
look there's proof that this thing that
I'm selling you works and they're just
citing one or two papers in a vast
literature that's going back and forth
the people arguing so how much should we
trust the scientific literature I mean
is the scientific literature true what's
here what's your thought on that well so
the thing that I would say is if so in
researching flamingo I looked back to
literature that went all the way back
into the 18th 17th centuries even so
these are people who were writing in
their time having just discovered
flamingos in the Caribbean and South
America and so on and they would write
these accounts and you know that at the
time that that was published that was
the sum total of what was known about
certain species or certain behaviors and
so you've got people saying yes
flamingos sit on their nests and their
legs are in front of them and bent just
like we would sit on a stool so they're
sitting on their nests like we sit on
stools and then you've got someone
saying no that's hogwash you know 40
years later we've reached the 18th
century where we know things now we've
adventured around flamingos definitely
incubate with their legs stuck out
straight behind them and you know fast
forward I don't know what it must have
been another hundred years and someone
finally said what are you people talking
about actually flamingos incubate nests
like every other bird they just tuck
their legs underneath them and that that
is true but you know in each of those
timeframes the people were reporting
what they thought was true
what a strange controversy it's really a
kind of thing but it but it does show
that all papers are just what we think
is true at a time given the knowledge
that we have and sometimes that
knowledge is because someone you know so
that very first guy he probably was
looking at flamingos from a distance he
didn't have binoculars that's what it
looked like so he thought that was
and he wrote that down the next guy
maybe he interviewed some people who
lived in the neighborhood and that was
what they told him and so he reported
that and so it really depends on where
your data have come from how those have
been analyzed how those have been
reported and all we can ever do is just
know that everything should be taken
with a grain of salt because that's the
whole thing with science is that the
very next measurement you take could
completely contradict every measurement
you've taken before no matter how many
there are
yeah so all of it is about saying what
percentage of all the publications are
reporting this particular thing how
rigorous were all of those publications
that are reporting this you know all the
people who do this the most and know
this the best what are they thinking at
the moment so it really is weighing all
of that up and keeping in mind that
we're all human yeah and and we all do
make mistakes but that little by little
we can add and push things forward and
so you're always improving you're always
honing I I took a class of course a long
time I was working I was volunteering in
a zoo I was in Knoxville Tennessee and
this was years and years ago and they
had this training course for everybody
who's new new at the zoo volunteering
and gonna be teaching people about
animals and wildlife and they had one of
the questions on their little test was
you know which which sources are
accurate and it's had like a news source
a blog and then a scientific journal and
they were arguing that anything in the
scientific literature is true because
it's peer-reviewed and that that's an
extremely common opinion unfortunately
ladies and gentlemen there's just
nothing that's capital T true there's
just not even the scientific literature
it's where people go to argue about the
things that they're observing and as
you've just mentioned here with the the
leg position even observations
observations that you would think should
be super clear-cut aren't necessarily
clear-cut and this is a you know this is
especially true when we're dealing with
things in genetics things and well you
know as I was mentioning earlier things
in what about diet diet science the
observations that we make trying to
understand cause and effect can be
extremely difficult and so there's good
reason for people to be debating things
so yeah I mean knowing that it'd be nice
if we could actually learn what's true
what's completely true but everything
really is a process so you had mentioned
that one of the things you can do when
you see a conflict in the literature is
you can actually contact the researchers
and this is something that I've I've
been doing from the start which stated
clearly doing my animations and it's
been extremely helpful and I'm curious
you know most people who are gonna be
looking at the scientific literature you
know people in my audience they're not
necessarily writing a book or creating a
video or you know doing something that's
major for the public maybe they're just
curious about something how when is it
appropriate to contact a scientist and
whenever you just bothering someone
that's a professor and has a bunch of
stuff to do I mean kind of how do you
judge that well so I think that
different people have very different
attitudes about where the boundaries are
and what a scientists or any researchers
responsibility is to the public I have
always been a big fan myself of reaching
out to people and I did this even when I
was quite young and I remember when I
was in high school I wrote to a o Wilson
eminent eminent scholar and you know in
my ignorance I just thought well why not
because his book naturalist is really
what made me decide that I I could be
the biologist that I wanted to be so I
wrote him a letter you know not really
expecting to reply justice just to say
this meant a lot to me thanks and of
course I never did hear back but I did
meet him later and he was a lovely guy
and I told him I had written him and and
he just said oh you know I just don't
ever have time to respond to these
things
and I can totally understand that on the
opposite on the other end of the
spectrum are people like me not not a
preeminent person and I do get I get
messages about my book I get messages
about my academic papers I get messages
from students who think they kind of
want to go into my area or come to my
University or just interested in the
kind of stuff I'm interested in and I
always do feel like I should try to find
a way to make the time to respond even
if it's a quick response
yeah and that's partly because I like
outreach I do outreach I think a lot of
younger scientists in particular are
really keen on public engagement because
there is this recognition that climate
change isn't great and if we connect
people to the planet you know we can
reverse that so I think a lot of people
are really into this but I definitely
think because my postdoctoral grant and
some of my undergrads and and PhD grant
money came from public sources you know
my science my expertise was paid for by
the public I want to give back I'm at a
public institution now I want to give
back and so I try to answer every
question that I can because I do think
you know we have been in a way paid for
by the public and so they should have
some sort of access yeah Oh a body Oh
Wilson you know he's I would say a
celebrity scientist right yeah so you
know he's been in tons of videos like TV
he's been you know he's been all real
place so reaching someone like him is
genuinely difficult but most most
researchers I have found now of course
I'm making a video so I tell them that
in the first sentence yeah which I think
makes people more eager to you know they
don't want their science then want their
science portrayed incorrectly in this
video but the I have found people to be
extremely accessible a couple years ago
there was a trend in high schools where
they'd have student they would assign
students to write a scientist and ask
some questions about their research and
people got super annoyed by that because
they were getting you know
if you happen to be popular if your
research happen to be popular among high
school students you're getting tons of
letters from kids that are obviously
just trying to get a grade on their
class and they don't actually care some
of them did obviously but but I have
found that most researchers will respond
to me and sometimes even when I'm not
talking about a video some of that I
just have a question if my letter is
super short and it's clear to them that
I read the paper of interest most papers
have a contact author they'll tell you
which person you're supposed to email if
you have questions and you know that
person's still alive it's a if it's a
relatively new paper you can usually get
a response and then the the other trick
that I've learned and I don't know maybe
I shouldn't be teaching people this but
professors someone's a professor they
usually have office time where they're
supposed to answer questions or meet
with students in their office and
they'll answer their phone during that
time if they don't have a student that
are literally talking to at the moment
so I found that if I'm not able to get a
hold of someone I can call them in
office hours and I'll pick up the phone
there are there are a lot of lists I've
seen circulating online now as well
where people who are willing to answer
questions and talk to schools and all
sorts of things will sign up and there
are a lot of subject specific ones or
ones with women scientists or ones with
women are people of color LGBTQ so there
all sorts of flavors of these and I
think that's really helpful as well
where if if you think I generally want
to ask about what it's like to be a
woman in science or I like biology but
you know how can I find the right
biologist ask these lists are out there
for the public so that you could
probably track down someone who's a bit
more amenable than just rather than just
taking a stab in the dark and finding
people on Twitter is also a new thing
that you can do because there's a lot of
researchers on there that are just
obviously if they're on Twitter and
they're tweeting about their research
they'll also respond if you send them a
message usually so yeah people are a lot
more accessible than you think again
if someone's a celebrity it's
like in the real in any other field if
someone's a celebrity it's hard to get a
hold of them because lots of people are
always trying to get a hold of them but
most researchers I don't know I feel
like research is kind of a lonely
profession because you become an expert
in one thing and you know when someone
when when some if someone writes you and
they have a genuine question about this
very specific thing that you've been
researching and it's obvious that
they've read the papers that you've done
and they know what you've written in
there and they just want some extra data
like it seems like that late you know if
someone writes me about the things I'm
super interested in I usually respond
it's a bit of an ego stroke I have to
say when I read your paper and I want to
use your methods but it's true it you're
absolutely right I think there's nothing
more exciting than when someone is
interested in what you're interested in
so you can geek out together yeah right
right let's see we were talking about I
pull up my questions here again so you
in your book you didn't just do
scientific literature I mean well first
of all what's the big difference between
older scientific literature and modern
scientific literature because you had it
you had to dive through everything yes
it is really funny when you do that as
well so I had actually I had previously
taken a history of science course which
I always thought was really interesting
I think people in my class didn't so
much so I was a little bit prepared for
this because I had read some pretty old
stuff before but it is funny when you
when you've got the people who are
basically you know they're just
explorers so they just go off on an
adventure and say here are the hundreds
of things I saw and then they say a lot
of slanderous things about the natives
oh my gosh this was considered science
back in the day so it's kind of just
like an adventure log and then you you
fast-forward a little bit you've got
kind of like your armchair scientists
victorian types you know like you're
you're kind of laypersons darwin almost
and those are a bit more experimental
but often they the the scientific
process is not entirely there from start
to finish or some of the ethics are a
little bit wonky and and it's quite
interesting as well when you read stuff
from the zoo literature or the the wild
animal literature versus you know
someone who's doing kind of the sort of
thing I do which is animal behavior
experiments or observation so each field
is very different and you do notice that
there are different languages as in the
jargon is different the the way that
they approach asking a question and
answering a question is different what
they consider to be a methodology what
they consider to be appropriate and
conclusive what statistics they think
are good enough to to come up with an
answer based on so you know back in the
day way far back in the day there
weren't even stats and then you got to
some stats that we would not consider
rigorous like maybe high school level
kind of stats today so it's just it's
really all over the place and and it can
be difficult to say well this this one
is as good as this one because actually
it's a whole other a whole other field
by that point basically yeah yeah I I
was just looking up stuff on
rattlesnakes a while back and it's funny
you go you back a little bit in the
literature and they're they're setting
up fights between rattlesnakes and
different animals and they're cutting
off the rattle to see if it affects
things they're injuring their cut and
taking a snake and cutting off its tail
then making it fight a mammal and see
what happens it's just like and then
yeah like you said this stuff they'll
say about natives where this stuff will
say it they yeah it's pretty interesting
going back in time the so aside from the
scientific literature you looked at
historical documents or how different
different cultures perceive the
flamingos and how did you know about
that like what where did you get it yeah
I found that really challenging
so in some of the other books in the
series things like owl for example you
know owls are around the world it's
quite easy
they're very prominent crows things like
that it is not hard to find these things
in other cultures without even looking
you know you google something and you
can find it with flamingos flamingos
occur only in very specific places and
some of those places are not places
where there is much of a long-term
history that you can access so for
example there up in the way for distant
mountains in Chile or in Argentina and
so of course there are local cultures
that have been there for a long time but
do they have things written down have
their oral histories been passed on to
people who speak English do they even
care about flamingos so if you find an
absence of flamingos references is that
because they don't care about flamingos
or because we just simply don't have
that evidence that I could access and
look at sitting here in England so it
can be really difficult and what I did
was I expanded beyond just the academic
literature so I was looking for
newspaper articles magazine articles any
kind of lay reference I was looking at
literature because you can then start to
see you know what's in the plays what's
in music what's in poems what's in books
so for example in in Africa there are
two different species of flamingos and I
was able to find some plays that
reference flamingos and then think about
what do those references in the plays
mean about how people might see
flamingos
you can search museums and see what
kinds of things museums have and in the
course of doing that you know obviously
if you're looking at visual
representations things don't always look
the same as a biologist would see them
it's not it's often changed it's often
very vague representative and so I was
writing people who were experts in
museums saying do you think that this is
a flamingo because I don't think it's a
flamingo even though it's labeled as
such so I was getting
back I was writing so in in the US and
the southern US and in the Caribbean
there are Native American tribes who may
or may not have some history with
flamingoes and I was writing people to
ask I have friends from India where
there are flamingos and so I was writing
them and saying look my understanding is
that these don't really feature in your
culture what do you think so it really
was this scattergun approach of looking
for anything I could find in any person
who was willing to talk to me
and it was it was quite an adventure
yeah that's really cool how many how
many actual researchers do you think
ended up the contacting and it would
actually help you out with this well so
off the top of my head I forget but in
my acknowledgement section there there
is quite a list so beyond just the
people who's you know papers were quite
useful I interacted with librarians
museum staff there were people at
flamingo and and wetland centers quite
helpful so I mean there were there were
several dozen people I would say with
whom I had actual conversations over
email or in person and probably the most
valuable was someone who was a PhD
student at my institution so that was by
chance actually I happen to find this
out that he was doing his PhD where I am
also based at the University of Exeter
and he has since completed his work and
he was doing his research on flamingos
at a wetland center that's about an hour
or so from here and I contacted the
wetland center and they were very kind
because they're all about research as
well as preservation so they wanted for
me to learn and to pass that information
on and so I was getting a lot of
information from people who are not
considered in the world of flamingos
like flamingos experts there even
culturist s-- they are people who hand
rear flamingos in captivity along with
lots of other birds my friend who is the
flamingo researcher you
he was a PhD student at the time and
often you don't see students being
considered the experts but those folks
helps me probably more than anyone so
you never know where you're gonna find
the right context and who's going to be
the source of information yeah well you
just mentioned that you know there's
these people are not necessarily
scientists that are that are earring
flamingos and doing all this I just went
to a reptile expo and was talking to
different people that are breeding
reptiles and I wish they would work more
the scientific community would work more
with them because they have knowledge
and information that's stored in their
brains on their blogs all over the place
that's more I don't think that
researchers have even thought about
thinking about so there's I mean an
expert an expert in academia might it is
good to dip into expertise all over the
place and just not just think of a
university setting as where experts can
be found yeah I've got someone asking
curious what is her opinion on Mayim Bay
eek yeah is that the lady from yeah yeah
the lady from the Big Bang Theory yeah
okay is that is that it that's the sum
total of the question of her yeah okay
so I have to say I have I have quite
mixed feelings because I think it's
great that she is a scientist and she's
very prominent and she's all about you
know being that in public and a strong
woman she has said a couple of things
off-the-cuff that I've kind of not fully
agreed with but then she has come back
and apologized for not thinking them
through
so that has impressed me so I I do
always think that a good strong woman
scientist is a great person to have
visible especially someone who will
stand up to being a stupid questions
like tell me what gown you're wearing
tonight and whose design is that when
when you know she's someone with the PhD
who knows about whatever it is she
studied astronomy or physics or whatever
but yeah I do think when you are
prominent and in the public you do have
to be quite careful what you say
especially when you have a big platform
because it can't affect a lot of people
yeah I mean this wasn't totally we
talked about maybe maybe talking about
this a little bit but kind of issues of
women in science it's a little bit off
topic of you know just how to how to
research how to how to do scientific
research but my my question for you
actually comes from me trying to follow
someone's work in the past this is a
couple years ago I was trying to follow
the work of Lynn Margulis mm-hmm you
know she did a lot of research on
endosymbiosis in bacteria and so on and
partway through her career she got
divorced and she changed her name and I
didn't know that
and so I her work was super interesting
to me and I'm trying to read everything
she done and all of a sudden there was
like it you know just her work stopped
you know and I end up getting on
Wikipedia and realizing that she was to
be sagen used to be her last name she
was actually married to Carl Sagan and
then then I realized this is so weird
because I'm trying to follow of research
on microbial evolution on endosymbiosis
and now I'm reading about someone's love
life instead and the dramas and
conflicts of their divorce like this is
a weird problem that exists because of
the way that we name people and our
culture that family names go typically
go by them the man and so this is just
it just kind of opened my mind to Oh
women professional women deal with
unique problems that men don't typically
have to deal with so first of all I'm
curious what you think about that
specific problem with naming a lot of
people get their PhD with one name that
they get married they change their name
that's got to be confusing
I mean you maybe I shouldn't be looking
at research based on one researcher
because that's kind of a good way to get
locked into one way of thinking maybe I
should be just looking at a topic but
but
what do you think about this like what
do you think about name changing as a
scientist yeah so I I was actually
married and I did not change my name and
I think I had always kind of planned to
not to change my name and and I was a I
had just finished my PhD at the point
where I was going to make that decision
and by that point I had already
published both in the scientific
literature in the lay literature and
even if I hadn't kind of tempted I I
knew that there would be that kind of
broken record and I didn't like that I
have friends who faced a similar thing
and they have kept kind of a nom de
plume if you like and work they go by
the name their maiden name but then on
their passport it's something else and
so they you know they did change it in
real life but they just keep publishing
under the same name some folks will do
the thing where they say you know nay
whatever their maiden name was and have
the whole thing so I have a colleague
who does that so she has both her her
maiden name and her professional name
and so I think you know people have
found lots of different ways whatever is
most comfortable for them to address it
and I think it's great I think you
should do whatever you want
it's kind of a pain that we do actually
have to you know think about this and
have these thoughts I think my favorite
of course is Callie and Zach Weiner
Smith having come up with the best name
ever so if you're you know freaking it's
double barrel it you might as well go
off but I think I think that the the
greatest thing now is that you can kind
of curate your own research these days
so with something like Google Scholar or
your own webpage you can make sure that
it doesn't matter quite as much so that
if someone like you wanted to follow
someone all through their career you
could just find now their Google Scholar
page where they have hand added in
everything even from when before they
were married and now they're married so
I think that that's maybe the kind of
the solution is to let people do
whatever they want with their names but
then have a chance to override and in a
sense through these archives
and and I don't know if all the archives
allow that to the same extent whether
you know with open access does that
throw a wrench in that makes it more
complicated I'm not sure but hopefully
that is a tool that can allow you to
adapt no matter what you decide to do
with your name yeah someone writes yeah
hold on yeah someone's saying Google
Scholar optimal list good paper is
accessible too I think I think that the
conversation here seems to be turning
towards a lot of people are talking
about enhance but also how to find good
research just in general as a public
layperson right just just to finish up
this little chat about names the the way
that I ended up finding following Lynn
Margulis was through Wikipedia all of
her stuff was listed on there so luckily
but that's kind of a rare case because
she's fairly famous researcher most
people don't have a Wikipedia page about
them and if they do it's not accurate or
not not complete your website has all
your literature on it I noticed that
that a lot of universities will have
their you know a page for each professor
and all the literature that they've
published so that that is super helpful
yeah I guess that's probably probably
just one small issue for women in
science that we could talk about but to
get back to this this question of how do
we find good research on the Internet
not all journals are the same right
right if something is published in
nature versus I don't know another you
know the a flamingo exclusive or
whatever how do you yeah tell us about
finding literature online right so
Google Scholar actually is really useful
and I have to say if I'm just you know
at my desk and I want to find something
I will just do a google search or go to
Google Scholar and do a skirt
that's search and then see what that
brings me and then take it from there
so I have to admit that even an academic
who will go the lazy route and actually
the lazy routes pretty good these days
so if that if that is all you have then
that's actually not bad and I thought
well you see it's a lazy but it's it's
the most accurate way right to find
research yeah I mean if you don't have
it access to something like web of
science or Cambridge abstracts or
whatever systems the universities are
using these days and you know the fact
that I actually don't know what they all
are shows you that this is what we do
these days we use Google so even if you
don't have access to those databases
that's fine I think it is challenging
when you are coming across journals that
you're not familiar with so I think even
lay people these days kind of know about
science or nature because they get
talked about so much as little examples
that you start to learn but if you're
approaching a new field how do you know
so my field has conservation biology and
biological conservation right so if
you're holding which of these are these
equal which of them is bed so actually
one is better than the other like there
are there typically are better articles
and one of those more consistently than
the other and so this is traditionally
where people have had they've used
things like impact factors so if you
look on a journals main page they will
list the if' or the impact factor or
various other metrics that are basically
designed to show how much are people
citing the papers within that journal
however you know there are some issues
with this because there could be you
know Mendel's work languished and
obscurity for years and years before
anyone published in but that was super
important so just because something's
not being cited doesn't mean it's not
important just because something is
online only and not in press in physical
press doesn't mean it's not important
there are lots of things that can easily
get buried because there's such a high
volume of stuff so there are lots of
journals now that will take anything
just because we want to try to pump it
all out so impact factor means less
there are papers like toast
impact factor is because I don't think
most people understand that and
especially how to read it there's a
number associated yeah yeah so I myself
don't really know the intricacies of how
it's calculated but basically the higher
and impact factor is the better because
that means that it's something that's
having more impact which means that it
is being cited more often mentioned more
often by other authors in their own
papers and with this each paper has an
impact factor or the journal in general
has an impact factor the journal in
general will have an impact factor but I
think there are also metrics on
individual papers these days as well as
individual academics so there are all
sorts of metrics that you can find and
you can find them on Google Scholar you
can find them on things like
ResearchGate all these different places
where they bring together academics and
academic knowledge so the impact factor
refers to the journal but there are
things about virtually every other
aspect as well yeah so just to be clear
to people who are really unfamiliar with
the scientific literature there's lots
of different journals and a journal is
just you know it's just like there's
different Newton you know there's
there's a New York Times and there's you
know there's all these different
literature companies in magazines and so
on there are different scientific
journals and they kind of have a name
brand so there's nature is one of the
most famous ones there's science the
scientific journal which is a really
famous one there's the Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences these
are all different journals and they have
their own staff that will you know if
you're a scientist you do some research
you want to get it published you send
your paper to these different journals
and their staff looks at it and says it
seems to fit with what we're looking for
and then they'll it gets peer reviewed
and then published if all goes well and
so these are kind of name brands I mean
nature as a name brand and what you get
with that name brand is you you get that
in the past they've been really good at
screening out garbage so most of what I
read in nature is going to be legitimate
and accurate and other journals don't do
such a good job maybe you can actually
hey to get into another journal through
some backdoor like shady deal which I
see all the time and and that in the
health food world is there are research
little articles that are published and
it's pretty clear that the journal
they're being published in is not
screening them that there's some garbage
in their data but the journal doesn't
care
journals can make money they can be
money making enterprises just like
anything else and today things like
places like nature you as a scientist
actually have to pay to get looked at by
by a lot of these places unless you
already have a history with them you
know working with them so it's it's a
weird complicated world we could do a
whole we could do multiple interviews
just talking about how to get published
and what the complications confusions
are there some of them also will charge
you to read their papers which is
something that people like me get
frustrated by because I don't work with
the university that gives me access to
all this what do you recommend for when
you find something you really want to
read and stuck behind a paywall
yeah academics are increasingly good
about sending papers to anyone who
requests it institutions are much better
about having a receptacle somewhere in
their library where by which I mean
virtual library where what we call a
preprint so basically the last edited
version of an article that has been
accepted so you take that's the preprint
that they're gonna take exactly that and
just format it in the journal so it's
exactly the same thing it just looks
different so they'll take that and
they'll archive it so that people can
access it so it's open access so there
are different versions of what's
considered open access and some of them
are the university or whoever will pay
for the journal article itself to be
free so that that will at the point
there is no pay wall or you've got the
lower level down where you've got the
institution keeping that copy that you
can access that doesn't look quite as
swish but it
it's all the same stuff where you might
have something even a bit more
rudimentary than that where it's just
put on the person's web page themselves
or they send it out on demand but but it
is there and I think all of those
options are increasingly common and we
do even find things where you've got
archives now if preprints that haven't
even been sent off for of you yet so a
paper that I used in a talk I gave this
summer which got lots of interests and
really great feedback it hasn't even
been published yet but it's just a it's
just kind of a review paper so it
doesn't necessarily need to be
peer-reviewed to be useful you know it
just provides lots of good information a
snapshot so even things like that that
aren't necessarily ever going to end up
in a journal could still be quite useful
so I definitely would say you know have
a look around to see if someone has
linked it to their Google Scholar or to
a ResearchGate or if it's in that
universities archive and if you can't
find it just drop the author inline and
they'll send you some sort of PDF so you
just email the author yeah definitely or
the the corresponding author so the
person that you mentioned earlier that
would have the little asterisk saying
they're the one to contact they will
inevitably send that out and and if that
is not happening if you're not getting
any response one of the other authors
would probably help or even the press
office of one of the institutions where
the authors are based so the press
office will often have a coffee and if
you are someone who's interested and
that might somehow be useful for getting
their name out then the press office
will want to help you and send it your
way yeah I found this to be extremely
frustrating and especially when you
consider that the research is paid for
by taxes and that's behind a paywall
and this is a trend that seems to be
dying it seems to be that more and more
things are gonna be published for free
especially now that we have online
publishing where it doesn't cost a
publisher hardly anything to host an
article but in the meantime there is a
lot of stuff stuck behind paywalls I
have found that one thing to do is to
copy a chunk of text because there's
always the abstract is going to be
online so the abstract is just a super
brief review of what the paper talks
about that's going to be online for free
always and a lot of times if you just
copy a chunk of text out of that put
that into google within quotes so it
only finds things that have that you'll
find a version of that paper online
somewhere a PDF it's been leaked or
whatever you'll find you'll find it in
most cases and I'm finding that more
common in zoology that I find it in
medicine and medicine stuff seems to be
protect a little bit better from us
peasants but the there's more money
there's more money behind that one
that's why right right so yeah try doing
that and then was it ResearchGate
yeah tell us about that so ResearchGate
is kind of like Google Scholar and
I'm I'm not I think it's probably like
LinkedIn where you can see a certain
amount if you're not a member and you're
not on there but then if you want to see
more you have to be signed up but it is
a thing like Google Scholar where people
will go in and they'll enter their
information and they'll link to their
publications so that is another place
where you could feasibly find someone's
PDFs and sometimes ResearchGate is what
pops up in the Google Scholar search if
you've been looking for a paper and if
nothing else they would have the
person's name and their contact details
that are often more up-to-date than the
ones from the paper so that would help
you then to figure out how you can at
least contact the person to get your
hands on their work mm-hmm someone said
Brian Stephen says that he is as Science
Buddies org I don't know if you've never
heard of that now I have an either
actually well Brian you can enlighten
awareness all right well it looks like
we're we've we've done an hour
conversation here this is good is there
anything else you want to like really
drive home especially about trying to
find papers or or reading you know we
didn't we talked about the anatomy of
the paper
yeah but anything any topic that you
think we should really chat about before
before I kind of trance
as this whole thing well I guess one
extra thing I would throw in there's
kind of related to something we did
touch on with changing trends and papers
and delving into the history is that
often I think there is a misconception
that whatever is most recent is the best
because it's the newest it's the most
advanced that's pushed the boundaries
and that might be true and it is perhaps
true that you don't want to cite
something from 1920 or Rita genetics you
know read something in genetics from the
1940s and think ah yes now I know what's
up to date but but it is true that
sometimes topics are no longer sexy they
go out of fashion and someone just sets
them aside and so things aren't advanced
or you know experiments are done but
they either keep finding the same thing
or they keep disagreeing and so there's
no conclusion so actually while it's
true that you want to try to read more
recent stuff and see where they are at
the moment in the research it's not
always true that the newest is the best
and that the old stuff isn't useful so I
think you should feel it can be really
good you can get a really good feel for
the the field and how it's changed if
you do cover quite a range as you're
browsing through and don't be afraid of
that older stuff even if it does sound a
little funny and look a bit different
from the newer things yeah yeah I you
know I typically when I'm starting out
on a new topic I will very first thing
that I'll do is I'll try and buy a
popular book written by a researcher so
just kind of describing the field
so recently hold on I got a unplug my my
headphones back in here so this book
endless forms most beautiful is a really
good overview by Sean B Carroll of
evo-devo evolutionary development and
kind of the you know where the field was
at when he wrote this book this was in
the I can't remember what year this was
written but he this book is absolutely
wonderful it goes over the history
2006 goes over the history of the field
the major findings in the field and that
gave me a good head start into and into
this field of evolutionary development
so evolution evo-devo for those who
don't know is kind of a combination of
embryology with evolutionary biology and
genetics kind of mixing those those
three things together which hadn't been
done until they started doing this
recently it was it was actually really
popular super early on like in Darwin's
time to study embryos and see if that
tells us anything about evolution but I
got read that that field got rekindled
recently so my first thing was to go
through that then I started getting
online and looking for reviews in the
field because this book was written in
2006 obviously things had changed since
then and then I started diving into
individual papers and that was that was
a process it was really helpful for me
so finding people like you who have done
these expert reviews and then going from
there to the scientific literature and
then then digging into the you know very
basic experiments individual experiments
that people have done if you really care
to get that become that much of an
expert on a field that's that's the path
that I've taken and again something very
important to note is that just because
it's published does not mean that it's
true the scientific literature is where
people argue about what - how we should
make sense of the data that we have they
present their data and then they
oftentimes argue about what that data
means so does that seem like a fair
summary and I think the other thing is
that often things that are true or you
know really good wisdom they it's not
always published so it's kind of like
what we were discussing earlier where
sometimes there are these amazing
reservoirs of knowledge and and this is
nowhere even in the literature so if you
think that you've read everything and
you now know everything you might want
to have a think about who else might
have some knowledge and are they
represented in that literature and if
not can you go talk
to them and find out so you know just a
really obvious example is like in
indigenous knowledge typically
underrepresented in the literature but
an amazing wealth of stuff so things
like that you can you can also think
outside the box about where there might
be extra expertise right well thank you
this has been great I really appreciated
it we should definitely have you on
again sometime maybe talk more about
issues of women and science because yeah
I mean we could go on forever about
about the you know kind of the changing
field of science seeming to have started
out as an old man's club and becoming
what it is today with you know today I
think I think we have it especially in
biology we have more female scientists
than male scientists it's just this
growing field but I I think the
leadership is still largely male and now
we're not really playing numbers games
with you know we need 5050 or else
there's obvious discrimination but
there's there are definitely special
issues that female researchers have in
science like we just mentioned today
with the naming just the naming system
of our culture is a problem when trying
to follow someone's research so that
would be that'd be a cool topic but
everyone thank you for joining us
and dr. kite special thanks to you given
this time and yeah stay curious
everybody so long until next week
goodbye